Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's leckeres Fingerfood und zwar so richtig, richtig knuspriges Fingerfood aus dem Ofen.
Und zwar benutze ich heute diesen asiatischen Filoteig und asiatisches Paniermehl
aber die Füllung ist so typisch türkisch, nämlich Schafskäse mit Petersilie.
Also eine richtig, richtig leckere Kombination,
die ich vor ein paar Tagen einfach mal ausprobiert habe.
Und die hat uns gut gefallen, ne?
[Hamza] M-hm, gerade zu Suppe schmeckt das glaub ich richtig lecker!
[Kiki] Ja, das hattest du nämlich letztens auch gesagt.
Da hatten wir's nämlich probiert und wir dachten: Boah, jetzt 'ne Suppe dazu - richtig perfekt!
[Hamza] Ich liebe auch an Ramadan wenn man 'ne Suppe isst und nebenbei noch kleines Fingerfood hat, so Börek oder sonstwas.
[Hamza] Weil man hat ja voll Hunger aber man fängt ja mit Suppe an!
[Kiki] Ja!
Und wir hatten sonst immer die letzten Jahre dieses typische, was ich immer gemacht habe:
panierte Sigara Börek, auch lecker.
Aber wir machen jetzt die andere Variante und ich hoffe, dass sie bei euch auch gut ankommt.
Ich hab jetzt hier einmal den asiatischen gefrorenen..Filoteig würde ich sagen. Den benutzt man auch für Frühlingsrollen.
Ihr wisst mit Sicherheit welchen ich meine, das seht ihr auch gleich nochmal aus der Nähe.
Und ich mache jetzt aber zuallererst mal die Füllung.
Da habe ich hier ganz normalen Schafskäse, ihr könnt auch Fetakäse nehmen.
Den mit der Gabel so ein bisschen zerdrücken und Petersilie hineingeben
und das ist schon die Füllung, mehr braucht ihr gar nicht.
Natürlich könnt ihr das auch anders füllen aber das ist heute meine Idee.
Und dann zeige ich auch schon, was wir für die..für die.. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich's nennen soll!
Auf jeden Fall tunken wir die gleich nochmal in eine Flüssigkeit und da zeige ich euch, was wir brauchen.
Und zwar verrührt ihr dafür ganz einfach das Ei mit Öl und Milch
und dann ist dann quasi auch schon die Tränke, wo wir das gleich reindippen
damit unsere Panko-Panade dran kleben bleibt.
Übrigens, die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen wie immer unten in der..?
[Hamza] Infobox!
[Kiki] Infobox!
Da fragen nämlich immer einige neue Zuschauer, wo man die denn findet weil ich sie ja im Video nicht nenne.
Ich find's immer so langweilig, wenn man dann sagt "200g dies, 200g das!"
Deshalb schön gebündelt zum Screenshotten.
Übrigens ganz kurz zum Panko: Das ist wirklich dieses asiatische Paniermehl, würde ich sagen.
Das findet ihr zwar in asiatischen Supermärkten, aber mittlerweile auch in gut sortierten deutschen Supermärkten.
Kaufland z.B. hat das auch, das hab ich nämlich gesehen.
[Hamza] Beste!
Genau. Und wir brauchen etwas Wasser damit das hier schön zusammenklebt.
Und jetzt zeige ich euch, wie ihr aus diesen Quadraten Dreiecke macht.
[Hamza] Einfach in der Mitte durchschneiden!
[Kiki] *lacht* Nee. Nein, alles falsch!
[Hamza] Sieht irgendwie aus wie so 'ne nass gewordene Küchenrolle!
[Kiki] Boah, du hast ja Fantasie! *lacht*
Also wichtig ist: Einmal in der Mitte zuklappen.
Es ist wichtig, dass diese Seiten hier gleich offen sind. Ich zeige euch gleich, wieso.
Einmal nach oben knicken
dann nochmal knicken.
Und jetzt müsst ihr euch die Finger befeuchten und hier schonmal
beide anpappen lassen quasi, also wie so ein Kleber.
Es ist auch super wichtig, dass ihr's hier auch nochmal nass macht.
Und jetzt zeige ich euch die Magie dahinter.
Ta-da! Wie ein Hörnchen. Und da kommt jetzt die Füllung rein.
[Hamza] Haselnusscreme!
[Kiki] Nee! Boah, das wäre auch 'ne gute Idee!
So, ich habe die jetzt soweit vorbereitet
und nehme jetzt hier auch mein Backblech mit Backpapier, gebe da ein bisschen Olivenöl drauf
einfach damit's nicht anpappt und damit auch nochmal ein bisschen Geschmack reinkommt.
Ofen habe ich auch vorgeheizt aber ich verrate euch gleich die Backzeit.
Denn jetzt kommt erstmal folgender Schritt: Wir nehmen jetzt immer ein Dreieck,
tunken das in unsere vorbereitete Flüssigkeit, lassen das gut abtropfen
und dann schön in Panko wälzen.
Und das Besondere ist nicht nur: Der Teig an sich ist schon so knackig und knusprig
und dann habt ihr nämlich noch diese Pankostückchen beim Abbeißen.
Boah, das ist so richtig double crunch, also echt lecker!
[Hamza] Man muss echt sagen: Das ist echt next level crunch!
[Hamza] Würde ich sagen. Das ist sehr, sehr knusprig, Leute!
Und vor allem dann in Verbindung mit der heißen Suppe - boaah!
Oder auch ohne Suppe. Man kann's ja das ganze Jahr über machen!
Die fertigen Crispy Böreks - soll ich sie so nennen?
[Hamza] Ja, Crispy Böreks, cool!
[Kiki] Okay!
Die fertigen Crispy Böreks werden jetzt im vorgeheizten Backofen bei 200° C Ober- und Unterhitze
richtig schön kross-goldbraun gebacken.
Und dann könnt ihr sie einfach nur genießen!
Ich würde mich an der Stelle bei euch verabschieden.
Schaut auf jeden Fall in die Videobeschreibung, da stehen alle ganz genauen Infos.
Ansonsten hinterlasst diesem Video ein Däumchen nach oben
wenn euch die crispy Variante, die ich mir vor ein paar Tagen ausgedacht habe, gefallen hat!
Und? Hamza, Taste Test? Ja, nein? Vielleicht?
[Hamza] Ich hab immer so ein schlechtes Gefühl, im Ramadan sowas zu machen!
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen: Ramadan ist erst in ungefähr 6 Tagen, also das drehen wir gerade vor.
Also - es ist eh dunkel!
[Hamza] Ja, dann wissen Leute nicht, dass wir die verar*****!
Okay. Vielleicht kommt ein Taste Test, vielleicht auch nicht.
Ich wünsche euch einen wunderschönen Tag.
Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!
Boah, ich reg die Leute bestimmt auf! Du machst diesen Klatsch, ich mach diesen Klatsch!
[Kiki] Aber ich darf den Klatsch machen, der gehört zu mir!
[Kiki] Hamza kannst du ASMR machen für diesen Crunch?
[Kiki] ASMR! 3, 2..
[Hamza] ASMR? Warte, warte. Wir machen das anders.
*leises Tippen*
*lautes Tippen*
[Hamza] Oh, sorry! Sorry Leute. So, ich mach jetzt ASMR, okay?
[Kiki] *lacht*
*lautes Knuspern*
[Hamza] *lacht*
[Kiki] Ich glaube jetzt gerade hassen dich ganz, ganz viele!
[Hamza] Warte, das war mir nicht knusprig genug!
*lautes Knuspern*
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Kiki] Für mich ist das sogar schon laut gerade, obwohl ich nur gegenüber sitze!
Ich weiß Leute, ihr verflucht mich. Gerade bestimmt wenn die Leute echt fasten sollten.
Nicht jeder fastet, ne? Manche sind krank, manche müssen nicht.
Oder manche sind einfach keine Muslime. Was auch gar nicht schlimm ist, ist ja normal.
Aber für die, die jetzt fasten: Ich glaube, die hassen mich wirklich gerade, oder?
[Kiki] Natürlich! Selbst ich hasse dich obwohl ich gerade nur gegenüber sitze und filme!
Ey Leute wenn ihr gerade fastet: so mega lecker!
Ihr müsst das unbedingt nachmachen. Das ist wirklich dieser next level crunch, finde ich!
[Kiki] Ich bin einfach nur happy, dass wir das heute abgefilmt haben!
[Hamza] Ich auch!
Mit der Suppe zusammen: mega lecker!
Leute, unbedingt nachmachen!
Abonnieren, liken nicht vergessen und peace and out!
Mit einem Haps sind die im Mund!